by the way uh ronnie got the um corona
virus vaccine
yes last night how's he doing
how'd you survive i know you were all
nervous about it uh how'd you do
he answered but you can't hear it just
guess what i'm saying sorry sorry
sorry why don't you remember to turn on
your uh button there it's easy to do
[Music]
all right anyway no i'm fine uh the only
thing is i got some muscle ache and
where i got the shot that's it that's it
that's the only reaction stephanie got a
little uh
lightheaded right after she got it but
then she was fine all right so you're
okay and and would you
would you uh recommend to other people
they get the vaccine
for sure there you go it's painless it's
painless
and ronnie puppet you got vaccinated as
well did that's right
and afterwards they gave me a lollipop
and a spiderman band-aid
i wanted a nascar band-aid but they was
fresh out
has it affected the boner that's the
most important thing are you able to get
it up since the vaccine i know you were
worried about that
i do i have a huge boner and last night
i had a little fever
so what happened was stephanie crushed
up a little tylenol
and put it on my favorite dildo and
jammed it up my ass
good for you